hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 alright we're about to roast
some biology ha
[Music]
[Applause]
hahaha Oh
skewing my vision so the game can
replace assets ha what silliness how
dare you how dare you
what a cheap and efficient way of
utilizing propria texture replacement
good job there red dot okay anyway so
we're moving forward now I think this is
where we're going yeah
and we're on our way to find out other
piece of roseto another stone like
object that's my standard hi I would
never I would never do that
hello okay you know that guy sounds a
lot like another crazy doctor that we
have in the first dead space that made
that you know the big guy and screwed up
all you again oh good thing I got this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I love my rocket launcher
what did I get what artifact is that and
it's another Billy location over here
but I do not have another Billy
I hate these sons of [ __ ] they're
really weird and creepy and disturbing
all right what am I looking for exactly
I don't see anything here supply oh
they're a friend in front of my face I'm
an idiot
that guy dropped tungsten are you
kidding me that's awesome
I didn't even think tungsten dropped
that's amazing I guess hey you [ __ ]
stand back
I have a gun I have my guns Hey look
another one oh hey you two live by I
start die
there we go is it peasy lemon squeezy oh
man I keep forgetting hang on let me do
this
just try buddy let's set up - oh come on
I need to put more dabbler John that
sumbitch right I need to put way more
damage on that you know I'm killing so
many of these individual guys I didn't
think that there were this many people
in this facility I think the perfect
specimen they're referring to is
obviously Bruce
Rosetta's lady one more slices are you
sure this is Rosetta only one way to
find out let's keep going yeah I think
she's starting to see that this isn't a
human this is not human this is a this
is a Necromorph of some sort either the
pure original version of the Necromorph
I don't know species creepy ass
or something I have no idea really
yeah I do not like these places give me
the heebie jeebies hi
who's there we'll be banging who's gonna
come tumbling through the roof
what are you wait what were those things
it looks weird
no you don't oh hi
goodbye black with the heart
alright we're okay okay I hear but I
don't have a belly I need to stop by a
bad stomach
[Music]
yeah yeah how about you go to hell and
you die
go ahead of you die oh damn lit I don't
think I have another tungsten Dubin
[ __ ] ah ah thank you passed me for
planning ahead holy hell brah good god I
saved myself so much trouble
thank you god I am so smart
hey I want an explosive module god damn
I got a lot of health kids
I need a bench I need a bloody bench
mate or need up all right I'm done I
shouldn't do accents I'm not good at
them oh all right ah Oh cor blimey guv I
need a bench oh I'm one of the tea
sipping sissies over in England they get
really mad when I call him that
apparently nobody sissies can't take a
joke yeah
[Music]
hi you sons of [ __ ] are gonna give
and if I had time to set up some traps I
definitely most definitely would right
now you're just being a hose and not
giving me time over here to chant ha I
actually rolled whoa it worked
oh yes it didn't work get off of me get
off of me
I said get off of me how about you go to
okay go away
Oh miss me whoa whoa Lily no deep Road
I'm not pro dodging it up one behind a
broom damn it there's a lot of you guys
I'm [ __ ] way
shotgun is good when they're far away
but now when they're close
oh come on reload you [ __ ] Jesus Christ
ah miss me Pro dodge damn it okay I
brought shouldn't have picked that
particular time to try to figure out how
to dodge correctly which I've only just
now started to realize is good man but
there aren't there a lot of goodies
filed on actual machine gun that would
have been much better good place to farm
gear I guess okay Oh what's this puzzle
what do we got here always in a message
over there I think it is well-known that
the surface of all markers contains
glyphs no one is entirely sure
this is a distinct language we are
treated to the marker screen
the structures we've uncovered below the
planets icy crust
I've ordered several artifacts yes I'll
stock lost no no okay
all right so if you're sixty off and
you're 50 I need to get this one to turn
60 in one hang on oh wait a minute
[ __ ] pass that's not right at all
ah how about why did that turn on her
why oh wait no how much does this turn
this okay that turns each one that one
turns that one nine ninety degrees I
think that one turns out one ninety
degrees when that happens and it turns
this one sixty degrees so if I turn that
one it needs to be able to turn in
ninety degrees
oh boy I am gonna be here for days yep
I'm gonna be here for it hang on hang on
hang on
okay so oh [ __ ] Ron wait mother I'm
gonna be here forever
god damn okay whoo all right try this
again she's gotta get that sent off set
that was the correct orientation just
now okay if I move this one twice now
oh we go I knew I had it the whole time
it's so great or something I'm alright
I'm mediocre I'm pretty I'm pretty me go
feed you what's that more diabolical
demons or are we just are we creating
another super Necromorph alright
no smoking roki King for a bit Juden
does anybody remember that house a long
time ago
Luke evening forbid Juden looking for B
Juden Luke evening Pharma Juden it means
smoking is forbidden
no effect let's wait wait I was wait
what trick are you trying to pull here
was there another exit there wait a
minute what are you doing wait wait a
minute
what we're talking about what are you
talking about what are you talking about
oh you so silly what's down here
what else do I need okay good okay I
didn't see that door my apologies for
being stupid oh there's the barracks
button up piss and vinegar my game just
crashed no why do I have such problems
with crashing recently god dammit that's
all I hate that so much okay I'll be
back
okay I'm back sorry about that I just
got through this puzzle in that area
again one things I don't like about this
game is the checkpoint saver system
other than that perfectly fine and a
little unstable when it comes to six all
right let's just move forward and carry
on with our mission don't crash it
crashed what the hell okay what the hell
is going on here that cannot be right
what's going on why is my game crashing
okay what it crashed in the exact same
place why did it do that why why why why
why you kidding me now I have to go
through all that again alright um I may
actually have a problem with my game so
I don't know what to say I'm just gonna
have to cut this short I'm very upset
that it is very worrisome and I don't
know why is anyone else reporting
problems of that particular location I
wouldn't hear I don't usually expect
triple-a titles like this to have bugs
where the game crashes repeatedly but
that was the exact same point and that's
a fair
a significant sign of there's something
actually wrong with the game itself so
I'm gonna cut this here and try to find
out what the problem is otherwise I just
be waiting still procore ting the webcam
for hours so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]